I am happy to join with you today in what will go down in history...
...as the greatest demonstration for freedom in the history of our nation.
Five score years ago a great American, in whose symbolic shadow we stand today...
...signed the Emancipation Proclamation.
This momentous decree came as a great beacon light of hope...
...to millions of Negro slaves who had been seared in the flames of withering injustice.
It came as a joyous daybreak to end the long night of their captivity.
But 100 years later, the Negro still is not free.
100 years later,...
...the life of the Negro is still sadly crippled by the manacles of segregation...
...and the chains of discrimination.
100 years later, the Negro lives on a lonely island of poverty...
...in the midst of a vast ocean of material prosperity.
100 years later, the Negro is still languished in the corners of American society...
...and finds himself an exile in his own land.
And so we've come here today to dramatize a shameful condition.
In a sense, we've come to our nation's capital to cash a check.
When the architects of our republic wrote the magnificent words of the constitution...
...and the Declaration of Independence,...
...they were signing a promissory note to which every American was to fall heir.
This note was a promise that all men,...
...yes black men as well as white men,...
...would be guaranteed the unalienable rights of life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness.